Nice work on functions up to this point. Now let's try this thing called the
composition of functions. The composition of a function is when we use two or
more functions together. The notation looks like this, f of g of x. Notice that
this symbol is not a multiplication sign. It's a small open circle, that means
the composite of g functions. It kind of looks like fog. But we really read
this as f of g of x. To see what's happening here, let's look at some function
machines. F of x will be a function that triples a number and g of x will be a
function that adds 5 a number. So, we're going to start by finding the f of g
of 3. What this means is, we want to find the output of g of 3 and use that as
the input for f of x. In other words, we'll get some output here for plugging
in 3 into g. Then we'll take this output, and plug it into f to get a new
output. So, we know g of 3, we simply take 3 and plug it in for x. So g of 3
would equal 8. So, now just really want to find the f of 8. We take the output
of g of 3, and plug that into f, so letting x equal 8 for this function, we'll
have 3 times 8 which equals 24. This is f of g of 3. Knowing this, what do you
think would be f of g of 5? Enter that number here.